et on continue de parler de valéry
giscard d'estaing avec l'écrivain et
journaliste andré bercoff bonjour andré
bercoff merci de répondre à nos
questions emmanuel map l'on rend hommage
ce soir à valéry giscard d'estaing comme
il l'avait fait avec jacques chirac
l'an passé une page qui se tourne ah oui
une sacrée page d'abord il faut une page
à divers cadeaux à ses traits à volume
en deux mots si vous voulez vous
rappeler qu'il faut se rappeler qu'au
regard des faits est avérée en 74e
pouvoir c'est-à-dire ses lapins en
france des trente glorieuses sont avait
appelé dès franck l'odieuse 2,45 à à
114,75 ça veut dire le redressement
après la guerre après le hockey mondial
l'expansion olympus réalisation aurait
été là et puis on est passé à autre
chose après avec la crise pétrolière et
où il a commencé à bouger je rappelle
aussi que le dernier budget en équilibre
de la france et par 1974 le dernier
budget en équilibre c'est à dire à la
mort de georges pompidou le prédécesseur
et après ça a commencé à se dégrader
jusqu'à la tête aujourd'hui que l'on
connaît un qui est abyssal bien donc
giscard super pls chose c'était d'abord
les réformes sociétales ça pour jouer a
failli rester là dessus vous avez
l'intention volontaire de grossesse
l'abaissement de la majorité à l'âge de
18 ans le divorce par consentement
mutuel après on a beaucoup parlé de tout
cela
la pilule et cetera lettres des pabx il
a il a joué à un progressiste de droite
encore la gauche ça ne capte pas très
bien andrée bercoff du coup je me
permets de vous poser une autre question
de temps vous pourrez capter un petit
peu mieux
est-ce qu'il a marqué une rupture avec
le gaullisme valéry giscard d'estaing
est claire non seulement là vous vous
attendez la oumma pas les lieux non
seulement il a marqué une rupture avec
l'ogc nice il a été la rupture avec le
gaullisme
n'oublions pas que car de gaulle avait
posé la question de son maintien ou par
1960 avec le référendum sur la région et
le sénat
giscard d'estaing avait voté contre il
paraissait c'est l'homme du 8 mai donc
il a marqué alors qu'il avait été minée
général de gaulle bien sûr nous économie
il a marqué structure neuve avec le
gaullisme est d'ailleurs le gaullisme
soyons clair le parti d'evolis sont
vengés en votant mitterrand en 81 et ça
n'a pas été négligeable dans les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
de 1981
on a vu un veau côté là des images de
valéry giscard d'estaing avec angela
merkel par exemple qui dit aujourd'hui
l'allemagne perd un ami boris johnson
également le premier ministre
britannique a dit valéry giscard
d'estaing est un grand modernisateur de
la france valéry giscard d'estaing un
européen convaincu mais aussi proche on
l'a vu avec le sujet de thomas bonnet
proche de la russie
comme quoi on peut être à la fois
européen et airs ce fils les deux ne
sont pas en pâtir
je rappellerai que de gaulle disait que
l'europe les l'europe de l'atlantique à
l'oural
c'est ce qu'il voulait d'ailleurs de
gaulle 1 donc effectivement on peut
parler de la russie mais je ne prends
pas pour quoi faire
c'est à titre purement personnel la
russie a une dimension européenne
évidente et la nier ce serait à mon avis
assez hasardeuse mais pour revenir à
giscard d'estaing où il était très
heureux pleins là il a beaucoup
participé à la fondation la refondation
à la construction accélérée de l'europe
et même vous savez qu'un ciel de tavaux
référendum en 2005 sur la constitution
européenne
la constitution européenne où 55% des
français ont voté contre je me rappelle
que jusqu'à avait dit écoutez il faudra
aller papoter revoter re voter jusqu'à
ce qu'ils votent oui
donc il était effectivement à faire
vendre européen de ce point de vue est
clair une ombre au tableau quand même
avec l' affaire des diamants de bokassa
une au tableau avec des diamants de
bokassa qui a évidemment joué et ceux
qui a joué aussi pour le dire dans sa
défaite
ne l'oublions jamais j'en ai parlé un
peu vous savez ce n'est pas un scoop ce
que je vous dis c'est que d'autres de
tours en 1981 il y a eu un dîner giscard
chirac un pardon mitterrand chirac ou a
été scellé les abstentions du rpr c'est
beaucoup 2 ap
elles ont décidé de s'abstenir vous
rappelez-vous par 1976 chirac qui a été
nommé premier ministre deux de giscard
mais il a claqué la porte de façon très
forte et très catégorique
deux ans plus tard et donc depuis le
divorce a été consommé et le divorce est
allé il faut le dire jusqu'à beaucoup de
gaullistes aux roms venus de gauche qui
ont voté mitterrand
eliane peux vous le dire parce qu'encore
une fois ce n'est plus un secret il
allait être de piles et de chars prix
était patron des gaullistes de gauche
qui appelait les militants les
sympathisants les adhérents a voté
mitterrand
donc il y a eu les erreurs qu'au cas ça
et puis il ya eu partis de la coalition
rpr udf il est qui est parti sans
laisser d'adressé
merci andré bercoff d'avoir répondu à
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et écrivain